I am very rustled because of games come
because of the fact that divas new map
got announced like 10 seconds ago and I
need to write the story up
mostly because I played Secura shadows
that twice shadows that twice a
fromsoftware game and it kicked my ass
so when we went to his appointment I
thought we're gonna get like two pods of
it both play but it tends I've only got
one so I graciously hmm gave what to you
because you are souls born until you die
yeah super into those games yes you have
the blood-borne platinum yeah I've
played Dark Souls more times than I can
count 1 & 3 2 just twice there's a limit
guys so I'll let you get on there and
honestly like the look of anguish yeah
as you were playing but I can't tell if
it was like a good anguish it's so good
it's a little bit above doesn't there's
nothing it was a very strange feeling it
was a very familiar feeling not almost
nostalgic like you go in to Sakura it
looks like a Souls game so you go in
with that years worth of souls
confidence the muscle memory you know
souls inside out you you go in there
confident this is my job that's how they
get you and then this game is so
different that it's like a shock to
their system so that difficulty like you
played Dark Souls 1 and then if you've
played doctors 1 enough times you've
basically you're fluent in the language
of souls and a lot always that means you
can play Dark Souls 2 & 3 with
confidence blood-borne kind of mix that
up slightly introduce some new verbage
and a few extra like the way you use
that language changed slightly but
fundamentally still felt like a Souls
game and because of that you had that
experience and you could get on really
well this it feels like another entire
language now I'm like no no one that's
it's like Latin roots like I just I've
learned French and now everyone is
speaking Esperanto
and I'm very confused so I mean one of
the properties that I know you're having
is like the tutorial ization is
definitely was non-existent so I guess
like maybe it was just because of the
particular part of the yeah that was
yeah they didn't really explain much
which is it looked like a chunk from in
the middle of the game and obviously it
stands to reason that all the tutorial
stuff had already happened far earlier
and they gave me the basics of how to
attack but there's so much more
happening in that game it feels like
it's way more active you can jump out on
at the press of a button you can like
double jump up walls you've got a
grappling hook that like had it finds
points and we'll grab a hook up to up to
those points you can hang off ledges it
is very much inspired by tenchu I asked
them about wherever they looked at tend
to and they go of course we want to make
a samurai game we wanted to have this
like super dynamic movement style and at
some point we did look at tent you and
you can see that immediately but it
still fundamentally feels like a Souls
game where you have these enemies and
that you understand how they work
eventually and you can really easily
like cut your way through them and then
you have this there was this one enemy
who absolutely kept stomping sam-i-am
the samurai general guy
[Music]
and partly was because he's very
difficult he seemed to have quite a lot
of moves so and like I didn't have
enough time to figure out his patterns
figure ice tells but he kept catching me
off guard and that's also because like I
couldn't understand his the way he moved
properly and also because I wasn't fully
like I've got accustomed to all the
abilities that were available to me so
there's like blocking and there's a
system where like you applying pressure
is an important part of it
because it breaks they're kind of God
and then once you break that guard you
get an instant kill you don't have to
like circle behind them and get them in
the back you can if you want but like
it's just about overwhelming them so
that's that like touch of blood born
there and then you've got like parries
and you've also got your prosthetic arm
which is that another touch of
blood-borne where you can basically flip
between different weapons on there so I
had like a flame almost like a flame
launcher that like close range would
keep people at distance chickens that I
could throw at from a distance and then
I had the axe from effectively blood but
that had like a way way longer wind-up
time yeah it was really it did a lot of
damage but it was like I couldn't get
used to how long it took to actually hit
so notice you're taking someone front by
surprise yeah it felt like in that demo
it was more useful for me to creep up
behind someone and then do a really
charged attack and also like the enemies
were way way more like Trixie they would
like run around a corner and then like
just be outside enough to think that are
they've gone and then come running back
round and like stab you and they'd
follow you around as well quite a lot
but they had like indicators where they
they could tell if you were yeah so I
was wondering if you could like possibly
like go in attack and like returned yeah
so the area that we were playing in was
quite small so that meant that it felt
like I was always in someone's corner
vision if I was on the ground level and
like breaking that line-of-sight wasn't
enough they could always sense me around
but it does make the kind of
their visibility moreover in the souls
games previously you just had this kind
of like invisible line which once you
cross there they knew you were there and
they'd run towards you you kind of felt
like it and by the time you when you
kept playing those souls games you kind
of innately understood so this one is
like a little more like it's obvious
that it's got an account like a caution
system as well like you're kind of close
to being visible here your your court
now and they will react like stealth
game characters where they're like hey
who's that and then kind of like they
won't say hey who's that they'll make a
crown over there
Stella is a big part of it like you can
go in guns blazing but immediately I
felt like enemies were placed closer
together so that they couldn't say I
looked over and like you're properly
getting strong yeah yeah and they do
things that and they brew or like they
would they hope they felt like there's
that one undead in Dark Souls 1 it has
this one attack which goes berserk and
sounds like a knife these guys were
doing that way more often like that felt
like one of their standard attacks it
wasn't like just towards the end or
anything like that so I frequently found
myself getting backed into corners and
forgetting it's the trickiest part of it
was having to unlearn what the souls has
kind of like taught you that kind of
like very measured style of playing and
it's almost like you have to unlearn
some world blood-borne is because blood
one had that like urban flow to it where
you go in attack back off this feels
like it's more like chaotic so like I
would be in the moment I mean like all
crap I've got I remember I've got my
dodge so you've got a Dodge it doesn't
feel as lenient it doesn't feel like
there's as many invincibility frames
right now but then you can do things
like jump backwards instead and if you
jump in the end press jump again he does
a little kick so you can like get people
away from you like that and then I had
to remind myself I don't have to stay in
this encounter I can just run away and
like zipline up to throw like a roof and
like use distance attacks or even just
try and hide for a bit or use grass to
hide myself and like come up behind
people and attack them and you've got
like jumping plunging attacks that are
very similar and some of them were
insecure I mean some of them want
because the enemy is too powerful
but I think my pervading thought was it
feels good to be bad at souls again
that's which is like an exciting
prospect and it's something that I think
they needed because now we got to the
point where fans we're just looking for
theme Matic differences between Souls
games like what's the next one gonna be
is it gonna be a Kakuna game is it gonna
be another one like you know dark
fantasy berserks tall knights are they
gonna do something else samurai stuff
this is going into a new theme samurai
Sengoku area era but also mixing up the
gameplay like fundamentally this is the
most change a Souls experience has been
since the first dog shows blood-borne
was a step like a small step in changing
that it's like really the one
yeah salt this is one giant leap for
Souls kind that's the yeah one giant
leap for Souls kind I'm very very
excited about this game and like I came
awake angry like livid that I would just
got absolutely stopped by a Souls game
and I was like I'm excited as well and
it also helps that you know Miyazaki is
involved so you're guaranteeing that I'm
kind of like quality the storytelling
hopefully and also like he seems to be
pushing be kind of like rising stars
within from software forward again and
they seem to be very much up to rise to
the challenge and it's just all around a
super super exciting prospect yeah
[Applause]